hi everyone my name is sai venom with
the IBM cloud team today let's talk
about Red Hat OpenShift
on IBM cloud first OpenShift it's an
open source application platform that
aims to make the kubernetes experience
better for developers and operations
team vet hat OpenShift on IBM cloud is a
fully managed platform from the ground
up this has a number of advantages which
we'll cover in this video it starts with
an integrated openshift experience
you'll get automated provisioning of the
infrastructure as well as configuring
openshift you can take advantage of
features for high availability to ensure
your applications will never have any
downtime and finally for all of your
monitoring and logging needs take
advantage of direct integrations with
Cystic and log DNA let's get started by
walking through the process of creating
an open shift cluster well navigate
through the dashboard and choose an open
shift cluster we see some information
about this service and we'll go ahead
and hit create now we're asked to
provide some information to start
creating this cluster we see an option
to choose between kubernetes or open
shift so we can go with native
kubernetes but in this example we'll be
working with managed open shift on IBM
cloud so by choosing open shift we can
then scroll down and choose a number of
different geographies we have multi zone
regions worldwide which enabled you to
have highly available clusters spread
across multiple data centers in the same
region next we have choices for the
default worker pool we can take
advantage of either shared or dedicated
virtual compute in addition there's
options for bare metal and GPU enabled
machines as well finally we'll choose
the number of workers that we want and
we'll go ahead and provision that
cluster the cluster will be ready
shortly but in the meantime let's go
ahead and jump to a cluster that's
already started let's see the IBM Cloud
console experience we can see a basic
overview of our cluster we can set up
something like key protect an encryption
key management service to encrypt your
applications and data and this even
supports bringing your own key
switching to the other tabs you can
fully configure the workers your cluster
is using this includes updating your
worker nodes as well as configuring
additional worker pools let's get to the
good stuff the open shift web console
here we have the open shift container
platform web console we can first start
by creating a project a project is an
open shift abstraction based on
namespaces but it has user management
built-in this means you get the best
practices for security from the start
with the project we can start by
navigating the catalog or importing an
existing project let's start by browsing
the catalog and choosing a node.js
application which comes with a
database attached we'll go ahead and
choose the default configuration options
and hit create within minutes it starts
to provision our application the
database the access hadn't even sets up
some routes for us this build is going
to take a couple of minutes so let's go
ahead and switch to a project where I've
already got this application running
well we have a deployment but the first
thing I want to do is actually enable
access to it will go into the routes
view and create a new route we'll go
ahead and make sure that it's connected
up to the right service and hit create
let's test that it works we'll go into
our routes and hit that hostname and
there we go we can access our node.js
application running an open shift the
open shift web console makes it easy for
day one tasks like building and
configuring applications for day two
operations tasks we'll want to take
advantage of the open shift CLI let's
take a look at the CLI experience with
the OC commands after installing the CLI
we'll grab the log in command from the
open shift web console we'll then open
up a terminal and paste that same login
command in a few seconds it will log us
into the cluster and we can get started
by first running the OC project and then
putting in the name of the project that
we just created we can run some
environment health checks here and
verify are running pods and containers
let's start by running the OSI get notes
command this is gonna allow us to see
the different worker nodes and the hosts
that are running within our cluster now
let's see the pods that are running in
our application we can run the OSI get
pods command with the - o Y parameter
this is going to allow us to see our
running pods as well as a note that
they're running in you can take
advantage of integrations with Cystic
and log DNA by accessing the
observability dashboard on IBM cloud you
get access to all of this in a single
location here you can access your logs
with log DNA and gain rich container
visibility using Cystic from its onset
Red Hat open shift has been focused on
making the kubernetes experience easier
and enabling enterprises to take on
cloud native development IBM cloud
builds on open source for advanced
capabilities to ease the pain of
security and scale not just on day 1
building but also day 2 operations and
across the lifecycle of the software
together IBM in Red Hat are building an
open hybrid cloud foundation built on
open source technologies and principles
to allow you to get started on your
hybrid cloud strategy the right way